Before we start, inshallah, I just want
to make mention that our brother
Hassan,
the youth coordinator, brother Hassan
is traveling to visit his mother. it
seems that she is unwell.
So we ask Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala to
heal her and we ask Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala to make her journey back to
recovery swift and rewarding.
If you want to reach out to him or maybe
message him or just make dua for
his mother inshallah.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
We are concluding the final verse
of surah
and then moving on to surah.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us in
the final verse of surah mud
which is a verse that is repeated
throughout the Quran
or its meaning
even if it has slightly different
wording is repeated in multiple places
throughout the Quran.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
in this verse Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
says that the Quran is a reminder
and
whoever wishes to refer to this reminder
and be reminded
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala then says,
"And they do not choose nor will to
remember except that it is the will of
Allah."
They do not remember.
They do not embrace. They do not follow
the path of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
They do not find benefit in the Quran
except that it is the will of Allah
except that Allah wills for them to do
so.
We understand from this that a person
who
wishes to be guided has wished to be
guided only after Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala has desired for him to become
guided.
Now
in this verse
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala predicates
our will
on his will. Subhanahu wa ta'ala.
We do not will something
until Allah has first willed it. This as
well is for tba.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions
that Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala he is the
one who
he is the one who
u guides them to repentance in order for
them to repent.
Likewise Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
he says
that you all do not desire or wish or
will
except that Allah has first willed for
you to will.
Now as we mentioned
that
this is a fine line and a middle path
between free will
and destiny.
We are not forced to make the choices
that we make. We are allowed we are not
forced to make those choices. We make
them with our own free will.
However, who has allowed us to make
those choices? Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
This is the path of the Quran. A middle
path. We don't have complete free will
in the sense that we can do anything
that we imagine. No, it's within the
confines of the options that we have
been given by Allah.
But then again, we do not have
no free will to the point where we are
automatons that have zero agency. It's a
middle path
that is sufficient
for the believer in his path to Allah.
When it comes to his end,
he puts in the effort. And when it comes
to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala's
recompense or response, that is to Allah
subhanahu wa tala.
The fruits of our labor come to us only
by Allah.
If you could imagine with me
a game of chess for instance.
Now
I have free will as a player in this
game.
I can choose to move the pieces wherever
I want
but I have to follow the rules of the
game.
Otherwise I'm not playing chess anymore.
And so I have free will,
but the choices that I may exercise my
free will in are limited by the rules of
the game.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has given us
free will.
However, he has willed for us to have a
finite amount of choices that we have to
make within the confines of our
existence.
We mentioned before also the levels of
decree. This is very important for every
Muslim to know.
The information that we discuss here,
the knowledge that is discussed in these
talks or or what have you,
these are largely not just optional
extra knowledge.
This is we are only usually speaking
about the most critical parts of our
religion.
The things which every Muslim should
know
about his book, about his messenger,
about his creator subala.
But there has to be an effort from the
person seeking that knowledge.
Why is that?
Because usually people are drawn to
entertainment.
If it has to be catchy, it has to be
entertaining.
It has to, you know, every time we hear
it, it's got to really just , you
know, tickle our fancy just in the right
way. This is not entertainment here.
This is knowledge
and knowledge takes patience and
diligence.
It takes
a lot of dedication.
And part of that dedication is that a
person absorb and question
etc.
Otherwise
a person may be exposed to knowledge for
many many many years and not really
learn anything. Why? Because they
haven't held up their end.
A lot of knowledge
is not exciting at first a story
or a motivational speech or what have
you. It's not exciting that at
first. Why? because you're you're taking
pieces of a puzzle
and until you are able to fit those
pieces together and you have enough
knowledge to where it connects and shows
you a broader picture.
It's not, you know, the individual
pieces on their own don't really warrant
much excitement.
But these are things that we have to
know about our religion. Especially
being that we live as a minority amongst
the majority of non-Muslims.
If you want to trace
99%
of all innovation in Islam, every
innovation we can trace it historically
to where it originated and where it came
from. Upon doing that we find a pattern
a very interesting pattern
that most of these innovations come from
where
they come from places where Muslims are
interacting and exposed to non-Muslims
and they are exposed to the ideologies
of non-Muslims
and they do not have the knowledge
necessary
to be guided out of those shooads
and that's where innovation comes in
most innovation when you trace it where
does it trace back to a minority of
Muslims living near or amongst a
majority of non-Muslims
they have holidays we start to make our
own holidays
they have saints we start to make our
own saints
They build their churches or synagogues
or temples a certain way, we start to
build ours a certain way. They dress a
certain way, we start to dress a certain
way. They have amazing stories, we start
to come up with our own stories, etc.
Why? Where does this come from? This
comes from what a mentions is.
What is alen?
that a person sees or hears
something from just he hears or sees
something or an idea and without
researching without verifying without
understanding whether this is in
accordance with the Quran or not
they in they it they accept it they
think wow that makes sense that really
sounds Good. That first point of
that is where the avalanche comes from.
And if you want to see what innovations
do to a people, look at the people of
the book before us.
Judaism,
Christianity,
even
possible, very possible
that even some ancient religions like
Buddhism
may have originated
as
you know starting with messengers of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
but over the years what happens
an innovation Here an innovation. There
a word here. Take away a word there.
Implement this. Stop implementing that.
Rearrange
until what happens? Until there are so
much innovation that it's not even the
same religion anymore.
That it's not even the same religion
anymore.
It is now a completely different
religion.
That is what happened to the religions
of the people of the book before us.
Judaism. Why did why was Asa Miam sent?
Because Benu is the followers of MS had
so changed and innovated the book of
Allah
that now they needed a messenger to come
to them in order to
revive the religion because it wasn't
even the religion of Allah anymore. They
were not even Muslim anymore at that
point.
Why was
our prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam sent? Because the religions and
the people of the book changed it so
much and added innovation to it so much
that it was no longer the religion of
Allah. Even the fundamentals were
changed.
And so we cannot afford
to live where we live in the time in
which we live and drag our feet learning
what Allah and his messenger have said.
We can't afford it.
And on top of that, we're having
children and pushing them out into the
world carrying the banner of Islam. But
they are just as vulnerable as a babe in
the woods. We haven't given them the
weapons that they need in order to
fight. We haven't given them the armor
that they need in order to be protected
from the innovations,
from the misconceptions,
from the ideologies of disbelief. And
it is a very dangerous time that we live
in. A time where the most ignorant
people are the ones who have the loudest
voices.
A time when the people of true knowledge
are very very scarce.
As a matter of fact,
most people,
many people, let me say most, many
Muslims today,
if you were to ask them, do you love
knowledge? Do you love the scholars? We
say yes. We say yes because
we are supposed to say yes. But then
here's the question. Say, "Name five
scholars to me, major scholars today."
Most will not be able to do so. And if
they are,
it is only whom they have heard of
through the news cycle. El jazz brought
a special on him. NBC brought a
special on him, right? Alam brought a
special on them. And we learn now even
who our scholars are through the screen.
This is no serious discipline is ever
learned through a screen ever. Ever.
Ever.
If it's not worth writing and printing
and traveling, it's not worth learning.
And so we cannot afford to be in this
situation. We have an additional portion
of responsibility
because of where we have chosen to live
and because of whom we are exposed to.
And then if we allow our children to
continue to absorb hours and hours and
hours of the ways and traditions of the
people who do not believe that Allah is
one, who do not believe the Quran is the
words of Allah. who do not believe
Muhammad is the messenger of Allah
and they spend all of their days and
nights with them
and then when they are so far gone we
drag them to the masid we say she I need
an appointment fix my son fix my
daughter please she take out your magic
wand from your desk and wave it over
them so that they can be a perfect
Muslim Again, this is where we are. This
can't be the case.
This cannot be our situation.
And we'll end with this. Had a man
brought to him, a man came to him and
said, "My son
is very disobedient to me. my son is
and that's considered not only a major
sin but punishable by law in Islamic
law.
And so
summoned his son
and he said your father
has made a claim that you are
disobedient to him
and undutifyful.
He said,
"I have a question."
He said, "Do I have rights over my
father?"
He said, "Yes." He said, "What are the
my rights over my father?" He said three
things. That he choose for you a good
mother.
That he choose for you a good name.
and that he teach you the Quran,
not just reciting the Quran, that he
teach you the Quran,
what it means, what it says.
He said,
"My name is such and such." It was very
bad, terrible name. My mother is a
disbeliever. She's a Christian woman.
And he did not teach me the Quran.
turned to the father and said
he said you
cut ties with him before he cut ties
with you. This is the result of your
actions.
Many of us look and we say well Noah had
a disbelieving son. Yes, but that was
not any fault of Noah.
It wasn't that he was sneaking out to go
make salah in the masjid. Don't want to
disturb the kids. Not pushing the kids
to learn anything with regards to Islam.
But when it comes to
school, when it comes to
training for sports at school or
whatever society is telling us is
important, no, we we rule that with an
iron fist. But when it comes to Islam,
it'll work itself out. He's a good kid.
Look at him. He He's great, right? Kids
15, 16 years old. Doesn't know how to
pray. Doesn't know how to say anything
from the book of Allah. Doesn't know
how to read a line from the Quran.
This is a tragedy.
And it's not just his father or mother's
failure. It's our failure. until we
start to see that we're never going to
make our way out of the predicament
in which we find. So having said that
inshallah we will conclude starting
the next chapter that we will be moving
on to inshallah starting tomorrow will
be surah al muzman
chapter number 73
chapter number 73 the first five verses
Subhanahu
Subhanah.
And
[Silence]
Sai wasallam.